[Music]
[Applause]
this is rogue theory we are gonna talk
about some some bull stuff going on with
Sony and Marvel and why the next
spider-man film apparently it's in the
called broken home children's lives but
adult who feel like children we're
ruining our lives most adults nowadays
the difference I have the mind of a 12
year old and I'm not I'm not afraid to
Matt Beebe yes local I was in state
local actor but actually I believe the
endeavors did not be local and
eventually residential also actor star
of things that I've watched you so that
I believe you guys reminder oh and I'm
Phil Molina by the way reminder also you
can listen to this show on the road
theory podcast feed it comes out way
earlier than the video version so make
sure to go subscribe to that where we
gave you podcasts but on this episode we
have rogue theories about a couple
things and a sequel an interesting
sequel that eyes for the matrix which is
crazy good to bring it back but yeah
mostly we just want to talk about
spider-man in the MCU or not apparently
in the MCU anymore and also what that
means for MCU characters also what it
means for future spider-man movies also
is Tom Holland on unemployment now like
exactly what are the ramifications of
this thing
so let's actually you know first second
kind of pretend like this isn't the
worst news we've had in a long time
because they don't have Iron Man they
don't have Captain America no no I'm
spider-man just saying but let's pretend
that we're not our lives aren't ruined
and I just want to know okay well what
if Sony doesn't ruin this and they do
specifically keep Tom Holland what does
that mean for a spider verse potentially
that takes place over at Sony I want to
hear what you guys think those movies
are gonna be
are they gonna be any good what are they
gonna be about Sony has I think 900
spider-man characters or something
what are you pitches yeah I mean I think
with the success of spider-man into the
spider-verse that they could go back
into the multiverse and then Spiderman
can have all of his spider compatriots
as his allies and then like you said
they have a bunch of villains as well
would you say like they would leave the
MCU that way to go away to explain it
right because maybe the Avengers are
gone and Tony Stark is gone and it
explains it right oh they don't exist in
this universe problem solved or is it
the same Tom Hall and spider-man or is
it like this dimensions Tom Hollands
spider-man I think they'd be crazy to
get rid of Tom Holland just our MCU one
and like his other alternate dimension
version of him or you imagining the one
we know is the one that travels so much
I think he's the one who travels to
another dimension and the Avengers
aren't there and so maybe they just
tightly wrap it up quickly and he also
chooses not to talk about it very much
right that's the key because the moment
you bring up the blip or the snap those
are properties of the MCU I think it's
kind of just like the Peter Parker Tom
Holland we've known who just never talks
about his old friends ever again
and his suit is not the iron spider it's
a new one that he kind of makes
something like they're gonna have to
find some kind of legalese screen with
the venom situation there they could
very easily just give him the venom suit
and yeah the symbiote and I think that'd
be a great opportunity to mix it like
carnage if we're to do like a carnage
than a movie to start introducing Tom
Hollands spider-man into it he could
very easily be like I don't know at that
very convenient case of amnesia and need
to like remember who he is or something
but the symbiote would remember how he
because I didn't really see venom did
that's that's what still inspired by
spider-man or it was this weird thing
where it was completely a venom
storyline with Eddie Brock and it still
followed a lot of the same rules the
symbiote came from the same place
there's still references to spider-man
there just is the spider-man universe
okay but spider-man is definitely not
part of it but going back in through
venom I think is definitely interesting
I know you felt like
the tones are wrong yeah it's uh that
right now like the Tom Hardy version of
venom just feels so totally different
like the truth the reason venom is a
popular character is because he's
derivative of spider-man and I think
that's one thing that Ruben Fleischer is
a venom missed out on it's not just that
he's inky and black and kind of bad and
a bit cannibalistic it's because like it
started as a black spider-man suit and
what would happen if a character who
hated Peter Parker was super envious of
his career what if something that used
to be attached to spider-man
feeds off that and it turns into this a
character with a life of his own but I
think that order of it is essential to
Venom's origin and his story so it felt
like the venom movie was missing that so
maybe we could retroactively league I
think that's a great idea that would be
probably you know so nice when
spider-man would be super cool if they
teamed up against carnage because
carnage is like my favorite of the the
rogues gallery for spider-man cuz he is
he's a maniac he's like take everything
my real killer venom could do but
doesn't well it's like did the Joker got
this imbued or something that's so cool
so if like if then they introduced the
the venom team-up with spider-man to go
after carnage that would be really
interesting and I would love to see like
a really gritty like Joker style carnage
movie where we kind of get this because
there's so much like adult stuff that
could come from having a serial killer
as a symbiote that we just won't see in
the Marvel Universe because it's just
too dark yeah like this just straight up
like he gets home and he's like hey
where's Ned and his skin is just like
sort of symbiote that would be rad I
know you say it's like kind of a tonal
difference but I mean I think Tom
Hollands growing up spider-man's growing
up he's gonna be out of high school soon
and so maybe you can like the spider
verse can grow up with Tom Hollands yeah
but it's not like he doesn't have like
adult feet like he's got trauma like
real big trauma he's got to deal with so
like they could very easily fit that in
that tone yeah you let Tom Holland grow
his beard out and then he comes home one
day
get the guys who did Superman took off
Superman's mustache to put maybe learn
from their mistakes they know what yeah
I get the quarter and yeah he reacts to
his friends getting skin mutilated
beheaded it turned into furniture and
and now we got a good movie with Woody
Harrelson a fight ain't a little boy or
or Tom Holland his spider-man gets into
this universe completely snaps he
becomes a serial killer oh sure
from him and then Venom's out to
stopping him from doing that right now
you're saying the actor Tom Holland he's
an acrobat he that'd be incredible
okay my my pitch I do actually really
like I kind of like more than my thought
on it is the going in through venom Rao
interesting idea to throw him through a
portal or something which was who knows
how that would hat like it's just like
hey that Sidewalk fell open or whatever
and then he goes through it whatever it
is but yeah he introduced him with a a
kind of buddy been a movie or something
that'd be really interesting yeah I know
you mentioned like a Ragnarok kind of
feel to that which is also kind of fun
but for me it's also like well Sony has
the rights to all the classic spider-man
villains so they could really do I mean
any of the spider-man stories that we
know and and really like are available
at Sony so as long as the right creative
team behind them is there so I still
want to see you know a Hobgoblin story
or I mean obviously I think we we have
to do a Gwen Stacy introduction and
story and you know introduce captain
Stacy and and I think that all of those
things can very much definitely distract
from where we weave spider-man in the
MCU here's it's not a critique but it is
a problem if the only movies we're ever
gonna get of spider-man in the MCU are
these two movies is that one of them was
great this feels like spider-man and
then immediately like every other
reference to spider-man in civil war and
also an infinity war and in an N war
it's - an hour stroke scale up so fast
where he's you know he had to stay
I'm your friendly neighborhood
spider-man he's like make that reference
a lot cuz we don't know him to be that
we saw one movie where he kind of was
grounded and then he literally is in
space for multiple movies and it does
feel a little bit like there's it's
almost hard to recover from that of now
sending back in the neighborhood but if
you do go back to Sony and you you don't
make references the fact that he went to
space you also do have him say maybe
flat out I need to get back to basics I
shouldn't be wearing a billion-dollar
suit that auto kills for me I'm gonna
I'm a genius myself I was already
working on a suit I came up with these
cool goggle things right like I'm gonna
make my own new suit he's not really
acknowledging that he can't say iron
spider suit and we can't say Iron Man
and he goes back to basics and then we
just put him on kind of our traditional
path but the key is the only way it
works is you have to keep the same
creative people behind it even though
Kevin Feige is clearly the the puppet
master that pulls the strings
brilliantly there are plenty of people
that are not Kevin Feige that are doing
a good job with this and you know what
even if it is people that guided
anticipate overs who got at that Amy
Pascal and Laura Miller but also
somebody else at Sony made venom not
terrible yeah Tom someone Tom Rothman
yeah especially I'm just saying go back
to basics that's what that's what you
would call it even right spider-man back
to be I mean that would be the easiest
way forward because if you just look at
how far from home ended even Kevin Feige
said after you know after that movie
came out what his ideas were for a third
spider-man movie and he will just want
to do a Peter story he's like he's
becoming his own man so he's almost
giving Sony their way forward and we've
done plenty of videos explaining how
there's enough there for a sinister six
movie pusher um based off of clues that
we've seen in homecoming and far from
home there's enough like villains in
that world to where all you need it's
just one strong leader whether it's a
Mysterio who's not actually dead and
then you just need his public
counterpart someone who's like Jay jonah
Jameson who's beating that drum and
turning spider-man dune into a villain
and making him vulnerable like well
you're right all they need is the
creative team they need Holland and they
need John Watts I would say they need
their screenwriters who's been working
with them and making that those movies
so funny and I guess we'll have to see
how much of a magic touch Kevin Feige
had but realistically they could make a
good spider-man 3 sinister 6 story of
venom crossover story that does not all
reference the MCU as
much as that would kind of break our
hearts a little because they think the
promises spider-man is his connections
to the other Marvel heroes they could do
it
spider-man is definitely the one that
like shows up everywhere right every
character gets a spider-man time and so
that'd be the bomber version there's
different versions there's so many
versions we were talking about a
Scheider woman
we we I haven't read anything about her
reference to her story is very
independent from Peter Parker or you
know one of the other versions of
spider-man like I wonder if they we
didn't know legally if they have the
rights to Spider Woman but like yeah I'd
be really interesting - I'm gonna assume
that they do characters yeah I run out
pretty quickly yeah yeah so I guess but
you're you're thinking maybe find a
different angle and for spider people
right yeah I mean especially with the
idea that spider verse began by showing
every every spider-man that you have
seen exists within the same multiverse
right so like hypothetically every
single universe we've seen is in this
multiverse so you could have you could
have like the the animated you know
like spider verse portal open up suck
Tom Holland out it great into the like
the venom universe or into another
totally separate universe that he has to
find his way back and maybe that could
be like a whole metaphorical like
finding your way back to the Marvel
Universe thing weirdly spider-man does
have stories that sound a lot like that
reason there is a more Marvel multiverse
is because arguably the Spider Man
character they kept rebooting them in
different other incarnations and they're
like well how do we justify all this
okay what if there's just a multiverse
and then they start to tie in other
heroes into that multiverse but like
Marvel Comics would not exist without
the spider-man character like he was the
most popular thing that kept alive
through the decades were other
properties weren't doing as well so like
the whole idea the multiverse is a
Spider Man notion so Sony has the
leverage on its side like as much as
we're fans of the MCU we this is the
best version of spider-man in my opinion
that we've seen in live-action but I
mean if Sony wanted to gain control this
narrative right now all they would have
to do is just get one of the graphics
people to take their
these line up and say okay here's gonna
be our next movies over the next three
years
we're gonna have a Spider Man 3 we're
gonna have a spider-man and venom story
we're gonna have all the other symbiote
stories we're gonna do a Harry awesomer
we're gonna do a live-action Miles
Morales and live-action Quinn Stacey
we're gonna end with a sinister six and
I'm like goddamn that sounds a lot more
exciting than Marvel space forward yes
and also Marvel can't do a lot of those
stories even if they do keep spider-man
yeah which is alright real things like
the character they've done such a great
job and with that they can put them
anywhere it's kind of like Hulk right
we're Hulk they don't have the rights to
give Hulk his own movie anymore so
they're just like well let's do a good
job putting that character everywhere
else I kind of did a better job with
spider-man okay I think we're all kind
of on the same page about what Sony
could do I'm still mad at ya so before
we talk about where that leaves the MCU
let's give some shoutouts to some people
that have it coming they might be us
hey everyone Eric here just a reminder
that if you enjoy the stuff we make here
at new rock stars you can find us not
just on YouTube or the podcast feed
rogue theory you can also subscribe to
the podcast inside Marvel for all of our
Marvel news and WikiLeaks our Star Wars
podcast with all the inside scoops you
need to know about episode 9 the rise of
Skywalker the Mandalorian love Disney
Plus and what green milk straight from
the Architeuthis iron nipple tastes like
it's a taste of wishing you could unsee
something subscribe to rogue theory
inside Margot WikiLeaks and keep an eye
out for even more new content we got in
store for you ok we're back and real
quick what if they got rid of Tom
Holland and rebooted it again how bad
would that be I have an idea
you surf this okay so Tom Hollands just
objectively fantastic right yes mr. fan
for stick so they can't have spider-man
did they say they can't have Tom Holland
no they can have Tom Howard just shows
up one day as a different character oh
we would so support that just a new guy
who looks a whole lot like He Who Shall
Not Be Named legally and at the end of
it all maybe maybe there's some kind of
like reality bending I was trying to
find like an ex man who can who can
shift perception of reality there's a
bunch of Scarlet Witch what I did find
in my research though is is that Marvel
you researched it oh yeah weak I was
like what how could you have somebody
come in and like stir the pot yeah and
so can't wait till Taman reads this
email you send please call me back
please no there's there's a number of
x-men entities like Phoenix and stuff
that can like that could really screw
with reality right so like we have one
of those that comes in it could it could
be the most powerful I quoted as the
most powerful mutant which was Santa
Claus that is a canon Marvel parody look
like I've heard that at some point Santa
Claus is in the Marvel Universe and damn
Han looks just like well you have
somebody who is chaotic neutral right
like he just does he does whatever he
wants but he is he could have Santa he
could he just has this weird prerogative
right just giving presents a good list
in a naughty list he's new he's judgment
cuz we don't know what his endgame is
yet behind big call what if Santa right
and decides to mix up reality suddenly
Tom Hollands a new character and
eventually has to work his way back into
being being Peter Parker everyone feels
like something's wrong but they don't
know what yet it can't be Peter Parker
though Oh Double Diamond actually like
that we worked in Santa Claus and do
another episode of rogue when you're
sleepy that he knows wouldn't that be
great if you just showed up as like the
big bad next to the Silver Surfer or
something the only way you can get rid
of Tom Holland is if you're making
spider-man Miles Morales now or
Wednesday so that's only way I'm okay
with it I'm sure there's a lot of people
who will not like that for other dumb
reasons but that's I think the only way
so that's one awesome rogue theory on
how the MC who could survive without
technically having the rights to
spider-man anymore okay
how else so house is gonna affect not
only the MCU
but how else
could the MCU still thrive without
honestly I mean I muttered it earlier
but they don't have Iron Man they don't
have Captain America and now they don't
have spider-man
well I we can worry about the other ones
but who can and you jumped in my head
really quick who can take your breath
away who can replace spider-man in fill
that void I am so excited that Disney
just got the x-men back yes so I want
them to reboot the x-men into the Marvel
Universe they can start them off young
because I love that I said the energy
that that Tom Holland brought to the MCU
but if they come back in and have like
young Xavier you could have our danger
like it of Iceman like anybody just
start them off young and they can be the
sort of new young presence like growing
into the next generation of Marvel
superheroes you were a big fan of Muppet
Babies yes oh anything the young version
I'm so more the x-men in general and
just getting a reboot I was next
children okay so you're so who in the
x-men are you saying is like like that's
gonna be our spider-man equivalent I
think our ganger would be good mmm
that'd be a fun one you haven't seen him
really you need someone wacky though
because like spider-man had this like
sarcastic energy that's like very you
know there's Deadpool which is basically
just spider-man if he were vulgar and a
murderer but yeah you need something
with like whips you know like
spider-man's got this potential to be
super super funny and morph yeah I think
what they're like try I think something
worth keeping to - yeah spider-man's a
crown jewel
I'm sure Marvel hates to lose them but
like when you're watching at guardians
of the galaxy movie are you watching
being like God wasn't spider-man in this
we're watching Black Panther it's like
this is great you don't need spider-man
to be in everything so why not just like
build the universe out from what you
already have like Sheree is an amazing
character who is similar to Peter Parker
in a lot of ways his hilarious is young
is a genius engineer like I wouldn't
mind if she kind of becomes what
spider-man currently was in phase 3 she
could become that
phase four kid who's reacting as a kid
does who has like a reference base and
is a bit smarter than the adults in some
ways like she could be that she could be
that role you have characters like young
group could be like the next like youth
character of the the Marvel Universe you
have the Eternals the Eternals is gonna
have like some kids
I don't know how excited I am about the
Eternals yet they do have some plans in
the works to have like that we don't
have to worry about like right now is
Johnny Storm gonna be the new I mean
Deadpool could be the new spider-man of
the Marvel Universe
like they do have a way forward it's
just like spider-man just kind of has it
all right there and everyone knows who
spider-man is personally I would love if
just Deadpool becomes what spider-man is
either like the Ryan Reynolds version or
if they have some new kind of younger
incarnation of Deadpool in the movie of
Deadpool goes back to high school or
something because I do think one of the
reasons I don't like Sheree filling
filling that role is cuz I mean she's
probably like a trillionaire you know to
me and she has access a princess the
princess she has access to everything
and so Peter Parker is is brilliant
a little side route the MCU went with it
is they made him seem real dumb like you
know what I mean like he doesn't mind
sense he misses a smarts he there are
some moments where he does some amazing
science knowledge dropping and you're
like oh right and that's the version of
the MCU and that totally worked for me
actually he is you know in in line with
star-lord right they and they have very
fun banter to write the Robert Downey
jr. version of I'm smarter than everyone
here and I'm going you know ten miles
minute River is fun for somebody else to
do but to me that's what spider-man is
so I like I need it to be this this
youthful energy but you know you were
talking about this or in general we were
talking about how the Russo brothers
keep trying to ruin your life alright
and so they they said the Easter Egg
Nobel was an Easter Egg at the end of
endgame and they're like just kidding
Eric everything they says yeah ya know
food would be great so it would be
really interesting cuz Nova because I'm
familiar is a high school kid basically
dude kind of richer brighter and they
did set up that idea a little bit with
he is to the Nova Corps which we saw in
the Guardians movie has been wiped out
by Thanos at it we didn't see it
happening but we have to assume they're
gone but yeah they're all gone so that
happens in the creation of Nova that's
his origin there's one last Nova Corps
member it could be the john c reilly
character or something but that person
essentially hands off that you know the
mantle of the Nova whatever to this high
school kid and then he's like super
powerful and amazing but he's also just
a high school kid and when he like tries
to go back to school he like missed too
many years too so he's kind of dumb like
and then he ends up joining a bunch of
other dumb kids too like it's just all
that energy that I used to think when I
would read it I'd be like I don't know
if this could be ever like pulled off in
some some epic way but the MCU has
pulled off dumb so well so many times
now that it's actually more fun to be
the dumb idiot than the the genius yeah
world at least yeah the nice thing about
Nova - is he can go to space and it
seems like Marvel's spending more and
more time up in space yeah it almost is
like they treated spider-man like you
you know was that letter somebody yeah
yeah they build their next universe
cosmically so they're bringing in
characters like Adam warlock Silver
Surfer it's all taking place offworld
maybe that's where MCU should go they
should let's worry about finding
characters on world unless they're the
x-men and see what else is out there in
the universe I mean they kind of have to
write because after that oh so you have
this like dot - your villain you kind of
have to go above that and the intimate
stories are like great and I want more
of that because I feel like I connect to
it a lot more than these like intimate
yeah you that would be fun the whole
like sexual we pitched a number of times
at the MCU needs to start jumping genres
right things doing a horror doing a
mystery or on foot let's do some late
nights just vision playing every part
there's a lot of really messed up ideas
within the Marvel Universe that would
lead to a very upsetting world like just
just the old Jessica Jones sort of thing
yeah by itself was like oh that's messed
up like that potential is really really
freaky so like it could get way worse
than that down the road yeah virtually
with the Hulk how's that work very well
well
don't get a lover sport the second we
introduce people has to happen at some
point they have to address that they're
going to be destroying more than
buildings each other's hearts yes of
course I still I'm gonna double down on
this Deadpool idea being the new
spider-man because we know that when
Deadpool loses a limb it regenerates as
a baby limb baby legs baby arms what if
he all he gets destroyed regenerates as
a baby and we deep fake Ryan Reynolds
face on a teenage body and is our new
Spider Man would I regret teaching you
what a deep dig solution everything he
calls out from work now he's a deep
baked me in which means just invite me
to where you're going I don't know what
deep dig means they just think it's a
verb
if you could spell it if you had to I
can't read didn't they do a Deadpool
thing where he was just a brain point
his whole body gets destroyed at one
point it starts of a brain and just
built it it's like kamehameha down to
atoms and he still comes back so like
spider-man spider-man spider-man
alright so speaking of bringing things
back from the dead the matrix is getting
a sequel now well this time later the
matrix by the way one of the single
franchises that that has like famously
nailed up a movie and then done sequels
that made people think I never want to
see a sequel for this again I want it to
go die yeah like I want people to be
punished at a charge for war crimes
because of this equals the matrix for
stick mister matrix but I do think that
that I it's it's so ripe that world that
they created and not nailed later um
that it totally would make sense to
bring it back especially now I mean do
you hear this thing that I think it's
some ridiculous percentage like maybe
it's most people or some some crazy
number do believe we are in a simulation
now it's a very popular idea you know
it's one of the many conspiracies it's
one that conspiracy theory lights that
if you could we could all just stop it
believing we're in simulations and go no
further down that rabbit hole
we'd probably be okay as a society
unfortunately that's a gate
there's so many other bad conspiracy
theories so I stay away from it what do
you believe it's we have to have strip
poker before I get into that
no I yeah I think the simulation is very
popular unfortunately or fortunately
right now
and it all starts we did that our matrix
rewatch and you know we found new stuff
in it recently and I wanted to go deeper
into this idea how right now in 2019 the
idea is presented by the to 1999 matrix
are more relevant to today's society far
more than they were to 9999 society so
it makes total sense to me that they're
rebooting this doesn't hurt that mr.
breathtaking yes it's gonna be starring
it Laurence Fishburne I'm afraid but how
that's the thing because if you do watch
to the last movie well they're ignoring
them well they have to be like okay that
was another that was another layer of
the matrix let's formalize this theory
section right what is this movie going
to be about if you remember the matrix
where in a simulation he's the one and
then other movies happen that are crazy
right
well they injured twin ends in a game
yeah you guys he and Trinity both die in
the end
does he a lot of people believe that the
real world is just another simulation
but if you were to die in that
simulation would die and they like take
him out on some because he had to die in
order to kill the Agent Smith virus
resurrected let's let's get this real
specific because they're listening right
the house key was it's just lana
wachowski lana which is interesting so
what's it gonna be about and I'll say
Keanu is coming back and so is carrie
anne moss Keanu is Pratt him having his
moment right now is probably why this
whole thing is coming back carrie anne
moss it was has one character on a show
those cancels so I'm also not surprised
that she came back she was green Jessica
Jones
so it got longer run than most of the
other ones did right sure but I guess
I'm saying she's not busy
so they're both definitely back and we
haven't heard about Laurence Fishburne
who's raking and plenty of black-ish
money he's just gotta come back you know
my favorite thing in the variety report
about this they said yeah it's gonna
starting County Reeves carrie-anne moss
no word about how they're gonna handle
Laurence Fishburne who played Morbius
previously so they caught him Morbius
but they talked about him as if he was
dead as if they're like what are they
gonna do about Morpheus this character
not only is the character like alive
he's the only one of those three in this
but also the actors alive - it's not
like what are they gonna do about Carrie
Fisher like how are they gonna handle
this like the the Murphy is one is the
one no brainer of how you bring him back
is whoever wrote that variety he fired
its guy almost got to be starring him
like it's got to start with here's my
theory like the matrix gets reset right
in nature the neo we saw was the sixth
anomaly and we know that past anomalies
look just like him at the end of Matrix
Revolutions a new 7th matrix is forming
the difference being that humanity's
given a choice of whether or not they
want to be enslaved they could be cypher
or they can fk'd cave orgies whatever
their choices but there still is a
seventh iteration of the matrix the
machines haven't been destroyed there
could be a new Thomas Anderson / neo
that gets born into that matrix and just
lives a life the way he lives or he
lives freed but he has to gets dragged
back in to saw some other kind of
conspiracy so in your version movie
starts you know we see green numbers
whatever so it says the matrix for mr.
fun for speak and then starts in an
office setting and it's Keanu Reeves
again and he has not been awakened yet
that'd be great that's that's one idea
the other ideas it wakes up like neo
does on the Nebuchadnezzar and he's
living in some world but he looks like
badass John wit Keanu now and he's just
living in Zion or living in the freed
world because he couldn't allow himself
to get you know back back in but because
you know maybe all the humans that
they're building or that they're farming
still look like they're you know maybe
they're being cloned so they
our older versions of themselves and
that's why they look the same that's why
you recast Keanu I supposed to a new
actor they can find some way to justify
that and he's living in the free world
but there's there's still like a cold
war there's some kind of covert covert
war between the machines and humans even
though there's in peacetime it's it's a
cold war and they're finding sneaky ways
to lure people back in the matrix using
like VR escapism pornography gaming all
that stuff I want to spin off of what
you're saying right there at the end
okay the original films were kind of
about the the idea of the upcoming
singularity computers kind of taking
over eventually we computers would be a
essentially would be able to have as
much intelligence to them as a human
brain and that's obviously just
inevitable and then this started to get
people into these crazy ideas of like
what if computers could control our
thoughts yadda yadda yadda and that was
a very fresh idea at that time and now I
mean the idea of kind of being plugged
into something is almost what you do
when you play VR so the question is if
you're bringing this back in 2019 the
first one was 199 right so all these
years later what what is the new
commentary what is it about what are you
trying to blackmail us with you know I
think I know so the whole whole idea of
like I'm not gonna be political it might
sound like I'm starting there but I'm
not but the idea of like fake news the
idea of us being you you being utilized
with our outrage in order to sell things
and to distract from really important
life stuff I wouldn't be surprised if
it's kind of about that because it's
this whole smoke and mirrors thing is
sort of the essence of it and I think it
would be really interesting to see Keanu
maybe being tricked or or maybe he's the
villain in this one maybe he's Agent
Smith because six seven iterations in
the machines would kind of understand I
think by the third time at least that
there's something up right and that's
why they created Agent Smith by the time
he honors character comes along that
could have all been fabricated and now
he's he's under the assumption he's
living as a character who beat
everything and is trying to stop someone
but that ends up being the next
iteration of some
trying to sell the matrix okay I think I
see where you're going
it's insane so I want to rewind it and
there's you have to do stuff like that
for this to work I know but that is how
kind of the matrix works you have I'll
say that you dropped it like really
simply like oh maybe count as the
villain but you actually mean like
that's almost like the twist of it it's
Keanu is back and he says he has a
mission but he doesn't realize he's
playing right into the machines right
news where they have put him against
someone he doesn't realize the person
they put him against is the next the one
exactly so he's Megan Smith zone gotcha
and there is a theory that agent Smith
is truly the one of the matrix college
right then he is the one who joins the
source and and threatens the matrix in a
way that neo is just kind of serving
that characters arc because the
computers but like by the time you have
a as frequent a pattern as that they
would have to have some sort of like
realization that they need did they need
to start tricking the things that are
trying to trick them you know it's
interesting is the whole idea of Neos
hero's journey was a narrative that was
a trick originally that's what the
architect was explaining that that neo
was an anomaly and in order to fix this
anomaly and keep it on a cycle so they
can reboot themselves every time the
Oracle came up with this idea of what if
I sent someone on a hero's journey each
iteration of the matrix but what she did
to screw that up is she created this
love angle with Trinity then neo chose
love over choosing to restore the system
so that kind of broke the cycle in a way
but yeah I think it's gonna have to be
another layer of trickery like they find
out like the way revolutions ended was
what if humans had a choice you know
that's what makes humans different from
its chances we can choose we're not on
these preset things but the first matrix
posed a question of what if humans were
slaves to machines right the next movie
matrix 4 could be what if humans chose
to be slaves to machines because matrix
ended with a choice what if tendancy
just said again about matrix 4 what it's
about but just process what we all do
all day with all our technology yeah I
mean think every day we choose to pick
up our phones we choose to plug in and
that's that's very much an idea that was
at the cyberpunk core of the Wachowskis
back in the late 90s and you know they
went so far with it in there and there
original trilogy now they can go way
deeper and turn the mirror back on
society and be like we choose to live in
simulations like we you know this is
something we created this monster it's
not like you know AI came in and they
lurked in when we weren't looking it
took us over because even beyond that
right I think for the people who think
they're living in the real world they're
living in this dystopia they're fighting
against this horrible like the horrible
machines or they think they are but
maybe that's just like another layer of
the matrix and the machines are using
that to keep people under yeah I could
see that great guys I'm gonna say that
that really went rogue right there at
the end but it all started with James L
McCune so you get the rogue theory of
the episode yeah this is for the Santa
Claus thing is that questions I have not
seen I did not write and I do not like
asking ready the just whatever comes up
guys all right the next James Bond movie
got a title this week no time to die
pitch me your best Bond title quantum of
golden [ __ ] the solace of death bond
takes a vacation to do baby bond guys a
producer for the Netflix series
daredevil paid fifty thousand dollars in
an auction for the main costume from the
series what's the one thing from your
old job you wish you stole or did steal
I feel like you stole things to this
mini staple staplers and staplers I
didn't take any staples old job things
you'd steal I used to I
my day job before I got into
entertainment stuff was I was customer
service for a motorcycle company I won't
say which I was the only person on
customer service and I would just
constantly think about if they can
handle one person for the entirety of
the continent for customer service I
don't want these bikes because there's
never so I wish I had stolen like a I'm
not gonna set up my model I'm on but
like an actual yeah I would definitely
steal this chair I there so weirdly
expensive yeah and like these are pretty
nice you should think about I would
steal so much of the SourceFed set yeah
which they started to give away for free
but then then other people have the same
idea and install reversed
guys the reboot it booted Football
League the XFL announced this week that
their Seattle franchise will be the
Dragons partly inspired by Dungeons &
Dragons which is headquartered in
Seattle
what's the dorkiest thing you could use
to inspire a sports team name they kind
of it kind of did it I don't know choose
what about the the Jacksonville natural
20s yeah you're on the team club it was
a pretty network usually I I went to NYU
and our mascot was the violet we were
fighting violets that's precious that is
the worst thing just but you were for a
sports dude is a flower but I'm not sure
okay we didn't have a lot of sports it
would have to be something really niche
like something real specific that nobody
would really understand at first
reference oh yeah if it was like the the
Noonan the Noonan K Bora Bora or
whatever the name of the lake the owl
from ocarina of time
that was actually raw guru in disguise
like if that were if just something like
real real specific that is but
intro the guy's eggs sweating trying to
explain yeah he was actually the owl
yeah he was actually a God but it was in
the shape of an owl and his head would
turn upside down death
stranding an upcoming video game that
could have been a bond named death
stranding an upcoming video game from
the creator of metal gate Metal Gear
Solid will let your character urinate
and then use that as a weapon oh my god
what video game would most benefit from
urine as weapons of all the things Red
Dead I don't know if Red Dead Redemption
would because like they're all covered
in urine anyway yeah absolutely
but in Mario Kart you can make a sonic
fantastic sonic could be hilarious can
you imagine how strong his his dream
would be if to have to like fight
against the wind of his Oh while he's
running when he's supersonic so he's
peeing this is a good into the quantum
theory of how he would piss forward
while being supersonic well isn't that
what they're doing the VFX retouching on
is just want to see no no no this this
brings up a bigger problem because you
have knuckles who is an echidna echidnas
have for penis heads thanks so much for
going rogue with us everyone thank you
so much to our guest James Allen McCune
where can we find you you can find me on
every social media platform as Jay Allen
mcj al le and MC I have a youtube
channel under my name James Allen McCune
and a patreon and that sort of thing
awesome great and also you'll finish on
your patreon for people who pay $10 or
more you'll find out what those four
penis heads do I mean what is different
I will give you one the higher tier you
go up you get
the mail it's expensive but worth it
guys that baby where can we find you can
find me on twitter and instagram at mt b
e eb e mo tip and if you're in LA the
first Wednesday of every month at the
Westside comedy theater I've got a
sketch show back at the Racquet Club
awesome great I'll take you out there
and then Eric we're gonna find you what
do we have going on this week on
Instagram atwitter a TA vos and on the
channel we have some interesting videos
coming we're gonna be doing deep dive
into the matrix and specifically what
happens in the matrix the second two
Matrix movies to set up this next one
and why they could be doing it some of
the stuff we've been talking about here
d23 is happening right now so maybe by
the time you're watching this you've
seen some trailers come out we know
there's gonna be one for the mandalorian
maybe some stuff about some of the
Marvel stuff we will be breaking that
down next week we another video looking
at dr. Strange's mindset because
according to the Russo brothers that guy
lived through 14 million six hundred and
five different futures and that means
his mind is over 2,000 years old so what
does that do to the human psyche and how
can that set up doctor change in the
multiverse of madness get a whole video
about that I'm really excited for you
guys
also you once did a video about if cars
in the movie cars right we have not if
there is a world war two in the car's
universe people to get the full spectrum
of would Hitler be a naughty would he be
[Laughter]
a stream car but it blows do not forget
to subscribe another question about how
cars do it describe to the road through
a podcast feed I comes up before the
video does stay tuned to the YouTube
channel for all of those things and also
that cars guys follow us on twitter at
new rock stars follow me at Phil Molina
on Instagram or Twitter this would that
I just got real terrible stuff in my
head now
about what's true in the cars universe I
got to go read watch that cars verse
[Music]